[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down
genv the first three episodes have just
dropped on Amazon and throughout this
video are going to be breaking them down
talking about all the Easter eggs comic
book characters and things you might
have missed when watching the show I'm a
massive boys fan read the comics so many
times watched the show over and over and
yeah this video it's going to be one of
the most in-depth things we've ever done
heavy spoilers ahead and we will be
covering this each and every week so if
you're new here hit the Subscribe button
to never miss a video without the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into genv episode one the
series actually starts off 8 years ago
when a train was first drafted into the
seven this is presented on the vsn
sports network and this being like a
sporting event makes sense you to a
train's power set in season 1 he ended
up having a race and was picked to be
the Speedster of the group due to him
filling in some gaps power set wise now
due to the news ticker on the bottom we
learned that he was handpicked by Clancy
Browns Brinkerhoff who we see throughout
this entry is working on his next protog
brof itself is a learning method
involving analyzing one's success and
failures and this is so that a person
can become their best the University is
also called God you and this is because
they're pretty much creating Gods duh
now there's a Deepa meaning for this as
the full name for gulin pulls from the
comics and it may hint towards what's
happening in the woods we will talk
about that later on in the spoiler fied
section so I'll not ruin that if you're
still reading the comics now in the
reports we also see the original 17
filled with lamp lighter and translucent
to the right lamp lighter actually is a
bit photoshopped in there with this
image originally being used in season
one and featuring Starlight now a train
is the first black member of the team
and this's arrival is pretty big news
it's obviously ripping off Barack
Obama's election and at one point meline
still well even says we live in a
post-racism world now which uh now still
well is once more played by Elizabeth
Shu who you'll probably remember from
that first
season
me you made my
[Music]
day in the comics James Stillwell was
the CEO of v and if you ask me he was
actually the most threatening guy in the
entire thing Stillwell was actually
jender swapped so that she and
homelander could have a thing and this
this goes to prove we live in a post
sexism World which now this is also a
memorable day for our main character
Marie Maro as it's the day her powers
manifest and she kills her parents Marie
Maro is of course a name using the
classic comic alliteration for a
character name and she's actually
appeared in the boys before during
season 3 when huie and Annie visited the
Red River Institute we had a moment
where the former hacked the computer
system one of the profiles there was
actually Marie setting things up for
what's to come here now we catch her and
assistant to taking a photo which
shadowed still edit a map for spotting
this is based on a Kendall Jenner
picture was Matt who spotted it I swear
it wasn't me I didn't have anything to
do with it the character ends up having
a period which also manifests into her
powers and she's unable to control them
in case you don't know the whole thing
with gulin in the comics was basically a
playoff Xavier's School for gifted
youngsters training the gmen John gulin
ran a team of youths which he used task
with infiltrating and keeping an eye on
he managed to do it but realized they
were just a bunch of kids who complete
morons that didn't hit the Thumbs Up
Button I'll talk in the spoiler section
about the end what happened with them
but it was more like a boarding school
rather than a university however the
X-Men metaphors are still strong
throughout with their powers manifesting
upon a big moment in puberty this Scene
It kind of reminded me a bit of the one
with Rogue from the first X-Men film and
her powers there were brought on by her
first kiss going back to the '90s come
come with me come with me mate but there
was actually an X-Men movie called Gen X
which is title also clearly ripping off
of wasn't very good but here Marie's
first period comes with her ability to
manipulate blood which can be used as a
tool of weapon upon killing her parents
her sister's the only Survivor and we
learn that she might still blame her for
what went down occur to present day and
we then see as Marie wakes up in the Red
River Academy we can catch someone
suspended off their bed floating in
their sleep and this is something
clarkent used to do subconsciously
during the show Smallville in the room
we can also catch a post of a homelander
and one for Golden Boy just beside
Marie's bed in case you don't know this
is actually Patrick swen anger following
the footsteps of his dear old dad Golden
Boy becomes a big character in the entry
with his death becoming one of the major
parts of the first three possessing
Thermon nucular Powers he's able to
surround himself in an oric energy which
makes it look like he's a burning ball
of flame there's actually a lot of
things going on with them in terms of
comic inspiration with the Human Torch
being the most likely candidate Johnny
Storm was was a bit of a young Playboy
too and he's seen as the favorite CER of
the group much like how a golden boy is
however later on we see a costume
designed for him and I actually think
this hints towards another character
that might have inspired him that is the
Sentry who two deals with mental health
issues and I did think they may be going
that route when he was getting the
visions of Sam the Sentry has a darker
side of his personality known as the
void which carries out evil acts and
Takes Over Control when his mind breaks
now like I said that's the vibe and I
wonder if Sam's got telepathic Powers
due to him reaching out to his brother
I'm not going to say Golden Boy fully
bouncing off of that but I do think
certain elements inspired what's going
on Sam is of course the student that
ends up escaping later on and Andre and
Marie obviously carry a lot of guilt
over this I think the central plot of
the show will be about exposing what he
went through and somewhat redeeming his
brother's untimely death now from here
we cuted the Red River sign which is
ironic on a number of levels Red River
is what my mate's bird calls her period
and Marie herself of course controls
blood this itself could create a Red
River and she might pull lots of blood
from other people to create a big wave
down the line now Red River itself's
actually appeared a number of times in
the franchise in the comics it was only
of a name drop with just a sign being
shown and nothing was ever cleared up
about what it really was however it was
thought to be a black ops military
contractor and its name was based off
the back of Blackwater now in the season
one finale when meline was pleading with
homelander she said that if she died
then her son would be taken there cut to
season 3 and Huey actually met a
teleporting kid who was theorized to
actually be mine's son later on when
Marie sitting in class A kid warps in
but let me know if you think that's him
CU we put that
in the Red River also showed up in the
boys diabolical and was a major part of
episode 2 in here we watched several of
the kids learning it was their parents
that gave them compound V and they
blamed them for their debilitating
superpowers hunting them down they
murder their families and I guess Marie
could share some kinship with that and
we see a counseling session where
someone talks about Starlight ever since
Starlight left the S I've just been
inspired to speak my own truth placing
this firmly after the events of season 3
later on we get some mave tributes but
interestingly nothing said about black
noir making me think there's been a
cover up and someone using the mask we
know that he will be returning for
season 4 though they could go the zombie
route that used to happen in some of the
Dead soups in the source material either
way V is integrated into every aspect of
life and we see how the clocks in the
school are made by the company the kids
are clearly being influenced into
thinking that's the way to get out of
there with brinkerhoff's book even being
studied in class downstairs she sees a
student being dragged off to almyra a
vun rehabilitation center that stops
soup stepping out of line later on we
learn this is what happens to kids that
don't get adopted and I think in the
series we'll discover what really
happens there soups can't be let out in
the world and checked because the super
villain potential there would simply be
too much thus at Red River adoption or
God you becomes essential because
otherwise they'd just be locked up there
you also see some sups adult movies
which will have to blur but they have
appeared in the series before namely
during that Lamplighter episode can't
really read out all the titles but all
the ones with homelander talk about him
cucking someone this could be an OD to
how he screwed Billy's wife with the vid
even saying homie bangs a wife there
also deep desert in the blow hole and
starai pulls an a train without actually
being forced to have to do it in the
comics on her first day in the seven
yikes now in the teacher's room we also
see a post of a homelander in the Deep
with a Starlight one there trying to be
inspiring the teacher here is actually a
carryover from season 3 with her being
the same actress that showed Huey around
now at this point Marie says I think you
meant to say first black woman in the
seven and it's clear that she's trying
to live up to her dad in the campus
video we meet some of the classmates
such as Rufus and also Jordan Lee as we
learn they have the ability to switch
genders so them saying they're super
inclusive is kind of a thing a uni would
leading to in their promo videos Jordan
is also an interchangeable name with it
being something that can be used on a
boy or girl sounds so like sound like an
old man there trying to learn new
phrases but we meet the invisible
student Maverick and also a telekinetic
one in a wheelchair later on with
Maverick they make a joke about him
standing there with his dong out are you
pitching a consent semar with your deck
out yes my dick is out common room at
three oh well like we we know from
translucent that he'd actually have to
be doing this cuz his cap and glasses
show his clothes don't go invisible with
him now lastly is Dean Shetty sparting
off all kinds of over-the-top sales
pitches that the boys of course love to
make fun of in the class we see a
character I think might Riff on Blue
Devil but let me know below if you think
it's someone else and the faculties at
the school are also introduced with a
school of crime fighting becoming a big
place there's the Crimson ctis for the
performing arts and she of course
appeared in season 3 played by Lori
Holden the cist was seen as being a
musical act so it makes sense that she'd
have this faculty named after her she
was also based on the Scarlet Witch and
they actually do a one division joke
later on in the entry it's an elevated
superhero Thing Really a meditation on
Grief told through 70 years of sitcoms
there's also Lamplighter School of crime
fighting with most of the seven coming
directly from there homelander was
actually trained in a lab and though
there's statues ever he's never really
mentioned in the school lineups also I
found it funny how a train and map were
ranked one whereas the deep deep was
just six shett also mentions how several
students have gone into Riverdale Pretty
Little Liars and so you think you've got
super Talent the students are welcomed
here there also clearly fear too as we
see reinforced Security on the doors
news reports are also used to cut up the
scenes with us see in the wake of the
final battle in season 3 which destroyed
the seven Tower blamed on the Russians
we also hear the defense of a homelander
killing someone at the rally which
closed out the finale his lawyer is
going with a standy ground angle and we
know from the videos that Prime's been
releasing on YouTube that he is going to
get away with it at about the 18 minute
Mark in episode 2 we also get a news
report with homelanders trial being put
in place a M's death also hangs over
things as well and I wonder if it'll be
on Earth that she's actually still alive
she's a big conversation topic though
were there being polls over whether vort
should continue selling Brave maves
vegetable lasagna speaking of selling we
also see the vort Run vay selling a
signed Funko Pop B that sits at
$1900 you can of course buy this Funko
in real life and I actually own it and
I'll give it to you in the exchange for
a thumbs up now from here we C to Emma
Shaw an Antman slw best character who's
able to shrink herself down however she
has to make herself sick in order to do
this which is a clear common umbia and
women feeling like they have to look a
certain way in order to be accepted this
is something that's touched upon
throughout the the episodes with her
story being used as a way to potentially
Empower women and get loads of views now
we actually get a clue to her doing this
early on as we see her reenter the room
to greet Marie showing she had to go to
the bathroom she's probably my my
favorite C you know and anyone who makes
my th will look bigger I'm down to be
mates with now herel is also called
David Caruso a CSI character which may
be a nod to how they're training to
fight crime now they do a little thing
about how the windows don't open which
if you've ever been to a hotel ask that
you you might know why they lock them
we'll instantly get demonetized if I say
it but it also gives the idea that
they're sort of Trapped in a prison now
that day at the arena they finally see
Golden Boy and his mate Andre known as
polarity he's following in his Father's
Footsteps or rather being pushed towards
having to become a soups the theme of
pushy parents is lace throughout these
episodes and the fact that the kids have
powers is because they made the choice
to inject their children with be they
were never going to be able to have a
normal life because because their
parents were the ones who took that
decision away from them and you do kind
of get the feeling that they're sort of
the villains in this situation obviously
they still love and care for them but
some of the things they say and do it
makes it clear they have their own
selfish goals now polarity statue lines
the campus and it's clear that he's a
big name amongst the other students both
are basically gen's version of Magneto
and they're able to manipulate metal and
the hearts of millions now speaking of
manipulation it's at this point we also
meet Golden Boys girlfriend Kate Kate
possesses Pusher Powers which allow her
to manipulate someone's mind and this is
so that they do things against their
will in the psychic Community pushes an
own to be able to do this and there was
even an xfile episode of the same name
that had a villain with that ability as
far as comic book culture goes I think
she's sort of in vain with Wolverine's
girlfriend and X-Men Origins who could
convince someone to do something simply
through touch at the end of that movie
she told William Striker to keep walking
and we learn that Kate did the same
thing to her brother which which caused
him to go missing the idea of the woods
there thematically ties him with the
woods which the group of course end up
investigating because of this Kate also
has to wear gloves which I personally
think is ripping on Rog from the X-Men
called in to see the professor Marie
comes across Jordan who gives her a bit
of a hard time at first but in the other
episodes they get closer Brink enters
with a bang and he comes off friendly at
first until we realize he's willing to
scap goat Marie to save his star
students in the courtyard we can also
catch a statue of soja boy but it looks
like he's had red paint splashed over
him this might be because of the events
of season 3 and potentially he's seen in
the batt light because of what went down
at this point we meet golden Boy's
brother Sam who we learn escape from the
woods we get some scenes involving it
and we can see the walls are papered
there to look like trees which leads
into what we'll talk about more later
now out in the courtyard the next day we
see the student in the wheelchair and
can also catch someone in a homelander
costume meeting up with him Emma and
Marie are both drinking jeta beans the N
Universe coffee house that appeared in
episode two of the comics and also the
TV series at this point we probably meet
Justine who talks about the one division
parody going out on VA plus they also
meet Robert baki's character and they
should call him Robert Small cocky hey
hey hey I going to kill
me n Brink's office he talks about
visiting golden boy's parents which is a
practice Professor Rex and Magneto used
to do it's a completely different
relationship to what has with homie and
it's clear he thinks he has the
potential to surpass him he presents him
with an a mage of a costume that means
he finally won't have to fight naked and
it's going to be a major difference to
his life as a whole offered either mave
or starlight's apartment he's making it
to the top to set the world on fire the
seven of course are also desperate for
members so it's not even like he has to
be drafted at this point he hears his
brother's Voice who becomes a go that
horns him for the rest of his life Andre
2 pushes Marie into the future coming up
with names like bloody Marie and also
coacula inviting her out they end up
hitting v tower whilst Emma stays in and
reads her YouTube comments I've seen
worse to be fair and along the sidebar
we can also catch several boys inpired
videos from the deep this is Super Size
Me one about eating a v burger for 30
days straight a vcoin one one with
Cameron Coleman owning the woke Libs and
another below it about interviewing
xwork and Tifa the back of her laptop
also has Brave mave on along with
several Stars just like her symbol that
v tower we see the construction to
repair it continues and can catch cranes
in the establishing shot the Marie for
the first time opens up about her family
having lied in the past to every other
person this is shared with Luke who to
talks about his brother being dead and
in the flashbacks in episode three we
learned this was a cover story he was
told but no it wasn't the case being
vulnerable and sharing her secret can
also be reflected in Luke later on as he
comes forth and teases the truth about
what's happening in the woods saying his
brother passed away he's of course had
to keep his mental illness a secret and
both share things with their siblings
that have kept them apart Lukas unable
to see this because of the words and in
the case of Marice she refuses to speak
to her they both share several character
similarities in this way and I love how
all the characters kind of have these
Shar themes between them Emma goes down
or or up on that guy and it is kind of
humiliating I think it sort of speaks to
the boys in general and how the soups
have to sell themselves in order to
remain popular they do lots of demeaning
things throughout the shows and Comics
because they know they can be replaced
easily if it comes down to it that's why
homelander going against us in season 3
was so important because it finally
showed that he was free from their
control now that isn't exactly a good
thing for the rest of humanity and in
the club we see how seps can become
outcasts if their powers go arai Andre
ends up slicing someone's Thro creating
a similar wound to what Marie's mother
suffered when her powers manifested
actually saving her this somewhat
redeems her death and I think right I
think it might actually be the first
time in the boys that a character has
truly saved a life I also think the coin
and metal manipulation may be similar to
Magneto who used one as a weapon during
X-Men first Class the way he floats it
is also similar to the TK uses in Looper
but it has the potential to cause a
shitload of trouble now Marie's savior
moment turns her into a viral sensation
but she's expelled after Brink whittles
off a story about Fred mallister who
comes from scabra been there a couple of
times but never heard this story and I
couldn't find anything about it online
if you're from the area and know though
make sure you drop it below but I think
not actually being able to find anything
kind of hammers home the point he's a
nobody who died saving his dog and he
embodies the sacrifice that the soups
would never actually make he chokes it
up to her actually being able to save
her friends but it's clear that she
doesn't want to be thrown out of the
school elsewhere we see as Luke gets
contacted by his brother and can catch a
deep movie poster on the right for his
film maximum kill Force mentally taken
to the woods this resembles the pictures
that line the wall and his brother Sam
begs for help which sends him off the
deep end that's not a deep pun it
doesn't even work anyway either way
Golden Boy goes off the brink and Cooks
his mentor alive in his office called by
Marie she ends up bleeing as Jordan buys
her time by hitting that dick just like
it's the like button now you might
wonder how they're able to go against
Golden Boy with just the gender changing
Powers but compound V also gives you
enhanced human strength most of the
users also get durability too with the
major Powers tending to be what's unique
to them outside we see Andre advertising
turbo Rush a train drink which appeared
throughout the series there two media
reporters with us meeting Jeff later on
in episode two and we learn he's the
social media manager of God University
who got his injuries tripping on the red
carpet getting Golden Boy
self-destructing is of course a major
story but he leaves Andre with a clue
that makes him look to his dad's statue
as we cut to the credits we get the song
Celebrity Skin by ho which itself
discusses all the trappings of Fame now
this is followed by a special message
from Ashley who too blames golden boy's
death on his chronic drug use this is a
similar story to what they did with
Drummer Boy and it Segways perfectly
into a trailer for the season however as
for us we're going to dive into episode
two which opens with a cover of Nothing
Else Matters seeing a sign for black
noir saying no luy lose this also leads
me to believe his death's being covered
up now this sign kind of resembles the
second world war poster namely the loose
lip s ships one about keeping quiet
something similar is done at the 7
Minute 20 Mark in episode 3 with a
crimson C his poster basically saying
the same thing the blood and gore is
being washed up where it becoming clear
the campus just want to brush it under
the rug back at v tower actually does a
little little on the- noose joke about
having to torch The Golden Boy action
figures that would do for delivery
speaking with the school council we meet
Andre's dad polarity senior and as she
shuts down the idea of talking about how
Jordan Le helped out in the fight due to
them being a nonbinary asan she doesn't
think it's going to sell to some of
their base which V's currently divided
over due to the Starlight and homelander
situation during season 2 episode 3 we
saw as huy and Co had a road trip and
travel past the homelander painting with
a Confederate flag as a cape this shows
that the corporations have to Pand to
all kinds of people to be successful and
it's something we've seen culture wars
being fought over in the real world the
big PR disaster is what happens if the
woods gets uncovered and it's going to
be way more of a problem than the
compound V expose was a Brink dying
means Marie gets to stay and she starts
to enjoy the celebrity that comes with
being in the top 10 she's the first
freshman to ever do it further pushing
her along to what her dad looked up to
now Jordan Zend Dro down and outside we
see people at the brink statue taking
selfies with a girl having Mr Fantastic
like powers to stretch out her arms at
this point we also meet Rufus wearing a
red hat that says make America safe it's
clearly ripping off the make America
agret again caps and homelander and
stormr push this idea at their rallies
we also see rufus's Pals wearing homy
t-shirts and this is so that they can
show their support one also says sorry
snowflake showing the direction that his
followers are going now upon using her
powers Kate's eyes get bloodshot similar
the nose beds that happened to the
psychics during Fire Starter as for
Marie she's blowing up on Twitter and we
see a photo shoot arrang for both her
and Andre polarity senior shows off his
costume on his phone and it's it's clear
that Andre is wrapped up in what his
father wants for him I feel that's a
theme running through the show with the
same picture being up in Andre's room
Mar is of course trying to live up to
what her dad wanted to with her
desperate to become the first black
woman in the seven we also meet Emma's
mother in episode three and learned that
she was the one who taught her how to
throw up we learned she was a host of
The vort Shopping Network before she was
fired so now she's pushing her daughter
directly into that life as for Golden
Boy I think you can tell he was pushed
into a life set out by a Sur for the
brink but he managed to break free from
this to meet a tragic end also with who
Patrick stat is in real life I wonder if
that helped to to channel his
performance now Marie's dad's gone and
all that's left is Andre and I think
this season we'll see him becoming his
own man Marie also indicates that she
could become her own woman too but
instead she doesn't go off script to
admit Jordan Le helped her out this is
of course a common on talk shows and how
the entire questions and answers are
scripted in advance no curveballs are
allowed to be thrown and everything's
all just PR with Marie even saying this
in regards to selfies you can say
literally anything to them and they will
still take the photo I feel like this is
a comment on the soups in general with
them just being corporate puppets
created to make money they're corporate
shells you idiot her giving Jordan
credit is very much a potentially
sacrificing her career showing that she
could have what it takes to become a
hero but she doesn't decide to do it now
in the drama Hall we get one of my
favorite Side characters from the series
with Dawn of the seven dire director
Adam Burke making an appearance based
very very Loosely on Zack Snider
according to the wiki his original dawn
of the seven suffered constant
interference behind the scenes with the
bur Cup being something that social
media demanded when it was released it
included brand new footage and a
recasting of Stormfront because of the
whole twist that we did not see
coming he said it he said it and the
reason that he's teaching here is
because he had his own meoo moment in
which he showed his dick to M Kelly in
real life she spoke out about rejecting
Harvey Weinstein and they're clearly
doing a comment on that with Burke being
involved in Hollywood and we then get
some Channel flicking and can see Robert
singer's campaign in full effect with
Victoria numus his running mate Victoria
is actually based on the character Vic
the vi who in the comics was the VP that
caused the president's death taking over
the role this Vault Plan gave the
company unrestricted access to military
funding which I think is the long game
involving Victoria they of course have a
whole new network covering the election
and the right-wing station that Cameron
Coleman runs haven't really shut down
their campaign this will likely lead to
the swing States going in her favor
which will put singer in the hot sea and
her at his side speaking of Cameron we
can catch him reporting on Golden boy's
parents who he puts across of barricade
of themselves in their home in reality
they're of course just mourning but
putting the blame on them shifts
suspicions from the woods and it has the
eyes of the public looking elsewhere
theam ends up ditching Emma and th she
then teams up with her new best buddy
Justine this all happens in the school
of crime fighting lab which feels like
it's building off the back of crime
analytics upb Tower talking about how
she'd love a v Burger Emma says she's
not hungry and this is likely due to the
association with her eating disorder
this is something she confesses later on
and both her and Marie's powers in many
ways revolve around them harming
themselves in order to be Unleashed on
her laptop when they're picking the
scenes we see several posters from dawn
of the seven and also termites movies
you might have noticed the big Crazy
Love poster to by Emma's bed and on the
screen we get a filmography and all this
stuff he starting fourth movie along we
can catch pocket romance which was
mentioned during one of Cameron
Coleman's news reports termite like you
know you know exactly who termite is if
you I'm going to be honest mate no one
who's seen the boys could ever forget
that senior not burned in my brain
forever and yet it looks like genv is
carrying on the Dick Tradition now the
other films include Nubian Prince a
black panther parody who appeared in the
comics he was also mentioned in season
one of the boys and had an entire
episode centered around his family
during the boys diabolical there's also
the Deep movie Rising tide which itself
was a parody of the first Aquaman film
they also bring up Brian singer's
parties which termite used to attend and
yeah I'll Pro I'll probably get
demonetized if I talk about what
happened at them but there's a reason he
he doesn't really work anymore now we
can also catch Queen Ma on the bong and
V likely profiting of her death which
could end up blowing over you learn
Justine's YouTube channel can barely
crack 10K and the expose of Emma pushes
her beyond that his is called spilling
the tea which is likely a parody on the
te spill Channel and know guys if you're
watching this do a parody of me please
I'd love to be included now we see Marie
visiting Dean Shetty and get a line that
constantly pops up with it talking about
how superheroes all act like they're
made of steel this is something Marie
repeats and polarity senior also says to
his son I feel like this Mantra may have
a deeper layer to it with it being used
to repress feelings and emotions so the
soups don't have to deal with the truth
they're all experiments who are led to
towards his life so a company could
profit of their image and abilities when
you think about it they're kind of
enslaved with the only prospects being
either popularity or going to almyra
none of them actually have true agency
and I think the steel metaphor May sign
to Andre's abilities he of course can
manipulate metal and it would make sense
if he's the one who broke the entire
system down in the basement we watch as
the dean travels to the woods which is
where she encounters a trapped Sam
getting injections in his back in the
back of his room we can also catch a
post of a payback which is the team
Soulja Boy L that we saw flashbacks of
in season 3 now Kade and Andre then got
to Luke's room which has the word
murderer spray painted on the door
elsewhere we see his Emma being exposed
and she has to deal with her secret now
being out in the open in the back of
this scene we can catch a crimson CEST
poster with a tagline being momento or
Dreer this means remember to DARE which
yet if you've ever been a drama school
the models like this always some
like that now you can catch Justin
getting a girl to Nancy R in her tail
yeah baby Nancy ring that and
recently it came out that she was the
throat goat that night Kate and Andre
start to uncover the conspiracy by
seeing a destroyed camera and doing a
fraan thing with them getting a
recording from Luke in the polarity
statue revealing the truth about Sam
they talk about how Luke Saidi died in
Sage Grove and at the start of episode
three we end up visiting the complex
this location comes from the main series
and it's where the more dangerous soups
were locked up at love sausage gets a
little Cameo that Concho it h but this
is setting it up before the events of
season 2 now in terms of more recent
history this is where they developed v24
which allowed the user to get
superpowers for 24 hours the first
version of V could only safely be given
to Children whereas v24 can also be used
by adults that night the show goes on
with Haley Miller and the heroes get
classed as a group known as the
Guardians of gulin no prizes for
guessing what that's a reference to but
it later gets short to Guardian after
Andre fails to show after seeing some of
Luke's body still lodged in the pavement
he decides to become a true hero and try
to get to the bottom of things now I did
Google the rest of the names on Brinks
laptop cuz normally they'll throw on a
production assistant or or something
when they do these kinds of moments
unfortunately I couldn't find anything
so but if you if you know let me know H
but we can catch the words on the left
in the folders and Sam's profile due to
the guards coming in he not only misses
the show but he lets his father down who
of course saw this as his big chance now
Haley Miller throws Marie off by
mentioning her sister who said that she
didn't want anything to do with her
throughout the episodes Marie's been hit
with constant flashes of her parents but
now she's had to suppress all that for
this pompous reality TV thing that she
thinks she wanted hitting her marks
perfectly she says she's made of steel
showing the dean's indoctrination is
finally getting through to her returning
to her room we see several items of Red
Clothing showing her they're already
pushing her to becoming this big blood
themed hero however it's too much and we
have her moments with an I reflecting
Emma vomiting which is unfortunately
it's unfortunately a subject I kind of
have to skirt around due to YouTube
monetization however this metaphorically
shows the cost that comes with being in
the Limelight and it often ravages one's
mental health when a thousand people can
tell you in an instant that your like
button joke was terrible it just gets to
you and it feels even worse when you
know they didn't even hit it now this is
something the pair continue to talk
about during episode 3 and it's very
clear that they are in denial about it
they say it's because because it's part
of their powers but moments like this
they go way beyond that now Emma's also
seen at a smallest during this which
highlights how little she feels about
herself now we see how Black Ops set the
woods is with the gods even killing the
school staff member that comes across it
we actually see a missing poster for him
in episode three at about the 11 minute
Mark which is such a it's a very you
know it's it's dark humor but it it is
nice that they paid attention to this
now Andre sees this and a god uses a
Sonic Ider on him which is similar to
how the boys use IC weapons to
disorientate homelander Kate comes to
save the day through using her Pusher
abilities and I thought was pretty funny
how all her stuff was just like getting
people to smack themselves and the balls
and stuff things up their ass now this
causes her to have pushed too far and we
jump to the final episode where we
encounter the sage Grove Center and see
why Sam was moved to the woods Kate was
actually the one who sedated him and
there the guilt lies at her feed about
what went on the death of Luke and grief
helps her and Andre grow closer with a
PIR getting it on after she comes to and
comes to hey S no and after Marie
has a heart to heart with Emma she also
has one with the dean who downplays the
truth about her sister's comets we don't
know if that's really the case and she
could also be manipulating her like she
accuses the news anchor of doing her
interview is studied and picked apart
and it shows the students how to act
which makes sense that they kind of push
these lessons because they are selling a
corporate product and the person doing
the real heroics is of course Andre but
his dad unfortunately doesn't see it
that way all he's interested in is the
glitz and Glamour and he of course still
holds a lot of bitterness over not
getting into the seven we don't know
exactly when he tried but judging by his
age I'm guessing it would have been
before at train this would have made him
the first black member of the team but
instead he lives a life where he has to
live vicariously through his son there's
been a lot of back and forth over what
happened with him and how he had a kid
cuz Ryan is the first soup to be born
from another soup thus I think polarity
senior obviously injected his son
knowing what would come from it and it
is pretty messed up when you get down to
it this idea of controlling parents is
exemplified in Emma's mother and also
Jordans who arrive when they're in the
middle of doing something in the
background we can hear water a man by
salt and pepper which you got you guys
are smart yeah you you can figure out
the subtext there and we see a guys
showing off their Kitty Pride powers and
walking through a wall and Jordan almost
always appears as a man to his parents
because that's how feel they'll make
them proud this carries on the idea of
how the kids have to suppress themselves
to be a certain way and I definitely
feel like the the whole parental theme
is the loudest when it comes to Jordan I
wonder if all the sex stuff with them
will have them being a girl because of
the whole multiple things that my wife's
told me about with her ex-boyfriends now
when they want to reveal the truth they
turn into a girl which shows the true
person that Jordan wants to bead's
embarrassed and ashamed by this though
and he feels like Jordan's punishing him
every time they become a woman woman
it's clearly a Comon on how some parents
May react upon learning their child may
be trans and it's sort of like how the
X-Men themes changed over the years to
fit different Aesthetics the scene with
Bobby and X2 was clearly a play on a
child coming out to their parents so it
makes sense to have this kind of subtext
in the show at the fundraiser we see how
charity bids a hell for an evening with
the deep but yeah we've seen what that
guy gets up to signed a trainers are
being given away too and Marie can't
talk about the truth with her parents
because of the whole psycho angle that
could come from it I do think this will
be weaponized later on to control her
and if she goes to expose the woods
they'll threaten to expose her now she
just says they with Doctors Without
Borders and this is a real life charity
that provides humanitarian Medical Care
pushed towards starring in a reality TV
show Emma sees how her actual mental
health issues and life are going to be
turned into a commodity for people's
entertainment this exploitation similar
to what Justine did and it's kind of
like how they commercialize ma sexuality
so they could just make make money the
corporations they don't care about the
issues but they see aligning themselves
with these causes as a way to make
profit now Marie's back in a red dress
and this again ties into the powers and
acts as a sort of reminder of the Red
River she came from asking Emma to help
her pee this sort of place off the first
episode where they joked about how the
pants she wore didn't allow you to have
a Wei later on Emma's recruited to
infiltrate the woods and I have to say I
thought her and Sam hit it off he's
obviously obsessed with his brother in
episode one and I think it would be nice
direction to take things to have them be
a thing now in the basement we see an
orderly pushing along a trolley with a
bandaged up arm due to the dangers of
her job there's also a flame powered
soup called Betsy before we finally get
to see Sam we can see a black noir
poster up in his room as well and the
cartoonish animals on the wall also
resemble the visions that the character
used to have answering a bunch of
questions on a homeland of duve she did
Peg me a bit cuz my favorite movie is
the Godfather and yeah I'm I'm a white
guy so funny her to not know the
questions and the fact she brings up sha
Shank Redemption could obviously play
off the fact that he's a prisoner trying
to escape his favorite movie though it's
Water World which could speak to him
being someone in isolation that's
brought back to humanity due to the
people he has to protect at the
fundraiser we get some God alumni
including a train and the deep I don't
know why but whenever this guy talks
just cracks me up I'm not defending his
actions though now it's during this that
Andre tells his dad about the woods who
already knows I feel like he's going to
have to make a decision to toss his
Ambitions to the side and actually do
the right thing and become a hero and
the woods is sent to lock down after
they realize someone's there em May
shove between some graphic novels which
include Wonder Wing which might might be
a play on the Nightwing parody swing
Wing payback and queen ma who's put a v
International a play on the jli Emma
ends up killing a God by crawling
through his ear and we close out the
episode with the pair surrounded by
several of them I feel like this is
symbolic on a number of levels as it's
very much a baptism Through Blood that
transforms the character this brings
things full circle from episode one
where we saw it was Marie in that
position both had their powers killing
someone the theme of blood and this has
taken them into a new Direction bringing
it beautifully to a close also I know
that Sam gets something injected into
his back at one point and potentially
they could be looking at ways to weaken
the soups I think that would make the
most sense as it would mean the Rogue
ones at these could be shut down without
posing a danger to society elmro was
hinted at in episode one and this would
bring things back from that either way
it's a big way to close the episode out
and I think next week we'll see their
escape attempt with the pair breaking
out Sam said that he knew all the
security codes to the doors and this
will help the pair both get out now as
for what I think's going on with Brink
and Co if we look at the comics it could
speak to what's happening full spoilers
ahead for them so if you're in the
middle of reading the boys and just
don't want to know then I highly
recommend you turn off now now it turned
out in the comics that gulin had
actually been abusing his students and
this dark secret was what he un cover
during his time with the gmen abducting
children from their families he built up
a system funded by V where he could live
out his sick desires whilst providing
soups for the company most of them dealt
with mental issues and acted extremely
immature and unable to fully process
what had really happened to them huy and
the boys were eventually cut out by
gulin and he then ordered his gmen to
just wipe them out however during this
moment V American SWAT team members
showed up and gunned down gulin and all
of his students turned out that V had
learned what was happening at the
mansion and fearing that it could harm
the business they decided to take them
out now whether they got that route
remains to be seen but I thought it was
at least worth bringing up at some point
in the video either way I really enjoy
these first three entries and it kind of
alleviated all the doubts that I had
over the show sharing that we were
getting a spin-off with all new
characters set in the University you
know I was excited but I did worry they
might just be milking the property
however this managed to recapture
everything I love about the main show
all these characters are really well
fleshed out and it's a great Coming of
Age story that deals with a lot of
different complexities you got pushy
parents Fame and wondering whether your
goals are even what you really want from
life there's some of that classic over
the top grow humor as well when they had
Emma bouncing up and down on that dude I
knew we weren't getting a dumb down
version I think the third entry was
probably the weakest of the three but
even then they're batting at a really
high average in my opinion going to say
it I think this might be the best first
three episodes of a comic book show that
we've had all year all the characters
are really memorable and unique and
there's the constant tongue and cheek
satire that I I love what the series is
known for genv didn't disappoint and it
really feels like The Boys Are Back In
Town terrible pun but yeah what a great
way to start the show and I can't wait
to see where they go next time now again
we will be back to cover the episodes
week by week and we'll no doubt drop
some videos in between with theories and
character breakdown so make sure you
subscribe can't say theories without
doing that stupid voice but yeah please
like the video and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us make these
breakdowns now if you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located just below the
video that'll let you pick up tops like
our Theory time one house to Dragon
stuff Marvel te's and a lot more we drop
new designs on there all the time too so
definitely keep an eye out for them and
yet thank you everyone who's bought one
now if you want some else to watch we've
got a video on screen right now that you
should definitely head over if you've
still got time I know' been here around
ling a lot it's been a very long video
but there was a lot of stuff to talk
about and I hope you guys have enjoyed
it out the way huge thank you for sing
through it I've been Paul and I'll see
you next time take care peace